you
sawdust no goblins you are a member of
the Nobel Committee in chemistry and we
have talked to them Nobel laureates just
for half an hour ago just before the
press conference what was your reaction
they were both very happy they were
happy and very pleased and I think they
share our excitement of this year's
prize it's a very good price do you
think they expected the prize I think
they it's there is a very difficult
question because there are so many great
discoveries made every year and during
many years but I'm pretty sure they know
that this or this is something big and
these are very important discoveries
brian kobilka was actually a graduate
student of Robert Lefkowitz as I
understand for some time ago was it in
the 80s yeah well as far as I know he
was a postdoctoral fellow with Robert
Lefkowitz and it was actually the two of
them together that cloned the gene and
sequence the beta-adrenergic receptor
and found the homology we were dobson
they had actually as they mentioned a
real Eureka moment in their life yeah it
was known at the time that there were
several receptors and it was known that
they all signal on the inside of the
cell using g proteins that has been
awarded before we were nobel prize but
they didn't know that the receptors or
that all the different receptors were
looking the same and when they got the
amino acid sequence of the beta
adrenergic receptors and so the homology
will be put off him they immediately
understood that also the receptors in
the membrane are built in the same way
and function in the same way and that
was a definitely real surprise in the
wake up moment and even if the receptors
were known before nobody realized that
are just the same no and it may be
difficult to understand that today when
we are so familiar with structural and
functional
homologies but we have to remember this
was baked back in the 1980s and not so
many protein families were discovered
this way so this is what was the hard
part of it yet the hard part a day to
obtain the sequence was a very was the
result of many years almost a decade's
hard work to extractive receptors and
get enough material to be able to
sequence it so this is kind of
laboratory world yes many of the
discoveries behind his prize or hard
laboratory works over many many years
not giving up even if it takes two or
three decades now they both receive the
Nobel Prize how important is it do you
think to be in a laboratory of a future
Nobel Prize winner I don't know if
that's important because how can you
tell and how can you know I think it's
important to be in a good laboratory
where there are great ideas and where
there is passion for science and where
there is persistence not giving up and
if you really want to achieve something
that you keep on going and don't give up
even if it takes two decades so the main
characteristics of the Nobel laureate is
not to give up even if you don't get
what you want yeah not to give up and
also to be very very smart you don't sit
around wait for 10 years to find a
solution they work hard at the bench and
they come up with smart solutions so
they gradually move forward and closer
and closer to the goal this is also a
little puzzling before because the
pharmaceutical drugs existed before the
receptors were known to chemists or to
medical doctors as beta blockers for
example they have been around for much
longer time than the science of the
receptors has been developed
how do they know to develop the drug
they probably didn't know that many
drugs that we use are discovered by
serendipity trial and error so the the
difference for the future will be that
now when we know what these receptors
look like the structures at high
resolution we know about this aspect of
bias signaling that different similar
ligands can cause very different
biochemical effects that will now lead
to the possibility to make new drugs
with fewer side effects do any of the
two Lords like leftovers and the Cobra
Kai do they have patents on the
receptors to be honest I do not know and
I also wondered when we'll listen to
this wonderful press conference that I
could also be perhaps in at the
Karolinska Institute and listen to a
press conference for nobel prize in
medicine how do you define the borders
between chemistry and medical I think in
them in modern science the borders have
been not a waste but the borders are not
as sharp anymore and both chemistry and
medicine or molecular subjects today
medicine is no longer just giving
something to a patient and observing
what happens also medicine it's a
molecular field and many great
discoveries are really at the interface
between the traditional subjects we were
talking about the research in the 80s
when brian kobilka was a postdoc at
Robert Lefkowitz laboratory but the
research is still going on and love
covets that mentioned that he is going
with the laboratory what is the question
today Lefkowitz today is working a lot
with this aspect of bias signaling the
properties of receptors that make them
able to respond to more than one kind of
substance and giving different responses
inside
cell and brian kobilka brian kobilka i
don't know exactly because they lost the
molecular structure it came out as lazy
September 2011 and exactly what he's
doing at the moment I don't know but
after that structure came out actually
in the same number of nature he also
studied the complex with another method
a my proton exchange couple to mass
spectrometry to confirm that although he
has so many tricks to get the receptor
to crystallize in the active state it
still looks like the real active states
that is not manipulated so it's still
ongoing science yes definitely RV this
is just the beginning of a huge field
this is wonderful thank you so much so
it's not a good answer for being good
thank you thank you